woke-ism
is so infectious because it fills the
religion-shaped hole in people's lives
true what i like i like that way of
putting it
actually so so the question can i just
read the rest of the question first
what if the best way to prevail over it
is to come up with a new religion-shaped
thing can you think of some tenets to
base it on
um so again i think you've nailed the
the phenomenon exactly right it's the
religion-shaped whole
and the problem is people who notice
that there is a religion shaped whole
in general in people when they lack a
religion
often come up with the idea that we need
to create one
which we don't um but
the idea that one has to come up with
something that conforms to those
uh constraints is probably right well
and i like the framing too in the second
part of the question
a religion-shaped thing right that's
what i'm saying exactly it's exactly the
right idea
right so in some sense and we advocate
for something like this
in our book not with respect to religion
but the idea that there are certain
human needs
that exist as a you know that they are
wired into us in a way that we cannot
just simply wish them away even if we
wanted to
right you know jealousy is actually good
good example of this right
jealousy is deeply built in and the um
you know the wisest people in the
polyamorous community recognize that
working around that thing
is a huge struggle and we can debate
whether or not it's worth it but the
point is you can't wish away the
jealousy just because
it doesn't make any sense in 2020 um or
because you find it unfair
right it's there so the question is how
can you work around the constraint
and there are lots of places where this
is what we have to do we have to
recognize what kind of animal we are
we may be living in novel circumstances
where that thing that we once were
is a bad match but you have to
you know jim rutt is fond of
saying that no system predicated on
a new man is viable right
yeah that there are lots of people who
want to rebuild
humans so that they can live in some
better way and the point is anytime you
do that
you've just told us you don't know how
to build the system so
no and that's i mean that's the other
place where that shows up in a more
common form
for probably everyone has heard like
when you're getting when you're getting
into a relationship with someone if
you imagine you know if you really like
them except they really need to change
in order to conform to anything you're
going to be able to live with like
no it's not that people can't change but
um
if if if having
if having functionality requires that
change will happen
in some way that you have in your head
you can't expect that it will be
functional
yeah and so just to say you know jim
rutt who many viewers
in this case just viewers will be
familiar with um but he along with
jordan hall who we earlier had a
question that included
and you uh were sort of a substantial
part of the game
b group that was talking about things
like jubilee as possible responses
right so we were talking about how to
build a system that would replace this
one would
preserve its values and not suffer its
uh
its harms and unintended consequences
and so we spent a lot of time
and basically the ability to say look
anything that depends on us being
different than we are
is not worth talking about right right
we are what we are and then you have to
build a system that works for that so
yes
yeah the religion shaped hole is the
point so
well done